don't be scared of 30 it means nothing
too many 28 year olds panic because
they're like oh I'm supposed to
have it figured out by now that's the
great lie of society there are some 28
year olds that haven't figured out there
are tons of people that don't quote
unquote figure it out until 42 and then
the question becomes what is figuring it
out figuring it out doesn't mean getting
married doesn't mean having kids doesn't
mean making a million dollars figuring
out is being happy joyful content and at
peace and you're not going to figure
that out at 28. it's too early it's like
trying to win a race in the first leg of
the race 28 is the time to enjoy it's a
time to mature a little bit like now you
got a few years under your belt you've
learned a little something you've been a
pseudo-grown-up for a few seconds so
it's maybe not like do the same exact
dumb you did at 18 but you're not
79 you're not 89 when I tell you I feel
pretty much the same as I did at 28. no
28 year old is gonna believe that but
every 48 year old's gonna believe that
and I think that's the secret of life
and I think people need to figure that
out